in the legal texts before all read a
at-michelle about mercy thank you thank
you and good evening to each and every
one of you this this evening we've just
published with with the government the
United Kingdom a full draft agreement on
the orderly withdrawal of the United
Kingdom as agreed by the negotiators on
on both sides
we're also together published in a
commented plan of the joint political
declaration on the framework for our
future relationship and all that is the
result of intense negotiations very
intense negotiations which starts in 17
months ago and I I would like to thank I
would like to thank our two teams that
the UK team and the team that has been
working to me for their commitment and
their hard work and personally I would
like to say that it's been an honor and
a privilege to have been part of a quite
exceptional team here now this agreement
is a decisive a crucial step in
concluding these negotiations it's also
the achievement of a method a
methodology which has been negotiation
carried out in transparency from the
word go and fully in the respect of
respective mandates now this draft
withdraw agreement
ladies and gentlemen includes 185
articles three protocols and a series of
annexes this this is the draft in my
hand here the draft agreement between
the United King
and the European Union there's no more
colors in here you'll notice there are
there are no more bits in green and the
way they were before and why it is the
new green so to speak and I certainly
hope that each and every one of you will
take some time some time to read calmly
and closely to read the whole of the
text this is a very specific and very
detailed document as you would expect
from an international agreement at such
an exceptional time in bringing legal
certainty to all those and there are
very many of them to all those people
and on all the subjects we where we have
to manage the consequences of brexit and
I'd like just to mention five of those
particular areas
first of all citizens rights citizen
rights have always been our common
priority of course that the priority of
the european parliament and of member
states as well european citizens who
live in united kingdom but also citizens
of the united kingdom who live in a
country of the Union and established
there before the end of the transition
period will be able to continue to live
their lives as before in their country
of residence they will be able to
continue to live in their country of
residence to study there to work there
to receive benefits there or to be
joined by their families there for
throughout their their lifetime and then
there's the financial settlement we've
agreed that the financial commitments
entered into amongst the 28 be respected
amongst the 28 all those financial
commitments together we wanted to
reassure all those who have prod
the regions supported by the European
budget in the Union and of course in the
United Kingdom and my third point there
there are many other subjects of course
on which we have had to reach an
agreement and on which we have reached
solutions to organize in each sector
this orderly withdrawal for example
those questions related to Euro Tom for
example the protection of intellectual
property existing intellectual property
rights the three thousand geographical
indications or some 1 million trademarks
drawings or community models and then of
course there is the use of and the
protection of personal data exchanges
before exchanged before the end of the
transition period but one fourth major
area where I think we found a good
solution is the governance of the
withdrawal agreement it is important for
us and it is important for United
Kingdom that this agreement be well
implemented it's all about the
credibility of the agreement itself like
for any international agreement this
draft agreement creates a framework with
a first stage of political resolution
for disputes and if there is persistent
disagreement the resolution of those
conflicts by an arbitration panel and
where the disagreement concerns
interpretation of the union law and the
European Union lore appears everywhere
in the agreement the Court of Justice of
the European Union will continue to play
its role and then fifth point we've
agreed on a transition period the United
Kingdom will leave the European Union as
the United Kingdom wished and leave all
the institutions on the 29th of March
2019 but for a period of 21 months from
the 30th of March to the 31st of
December 2020
we have agreed to preserve the current
situation with respect to the internal
market with respect to the customs union
and with respect to European policies
and all the rights and obligations that
go along with that
this will enable the citizens but also
administration's and of course business
and in particular small and medium-sized
undertakings to prepare and to adapt but
to adapt just the ones to change before
the implementation of the future
relationship we also have the
possibility of extending this once for a
limited period by joint agreement ladies
and gentlemen our agreement also
includes three protocols one of those
protocols is on Gibraltar that creates
the basis for administrative cooperation
on a series of subjects the rights of
citizens taxation tobacco the
environment fisheries but also police
and customs cooperation the Gibraltar
protocol is part of a broader package of
bilateral agreements between Spain and
the United Kingdom which relate to
Gibraltar I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank the two governments
for that bilateral work the second
protocol relates to Cyprus and the
sovereign bases in Cyprus this enables
the continuity of existing agreements in
and around these bases between Cyprus
and the United Kingdom in particular to
a label the 11000 Cypriot citizens
established our own territories under
British sovereignty to continue to live
as they do today
third protocol concerns Ireland and
Northern Ireland
we have now found a solution together
with the UK to avoid our border and
Ireland violent first we will use our
best endeavours to solve this issue for
the long term through a future agreement
if we are not ready by July 2020 we
could only consider extending the
transition to provide for more time on
leave at the end of the transition
extended or not we are still not there
with a future agreement with the
backstop solution that we agreed today
kicking this backstop solution has
evolved considerably from the original
EU proposal from February this year over
the last few weeks we have worked with
the UK on the basis of their proposal in
the backstop scenario we agreed to
create the EU Ukraine single customs
territory north on Island will therefore
remain in this same custom territory at
the rest of the UK
in addition Northern Ireland would
remain aligned to those rules of the
single market that are essential for
avoiding our border
this concerns agriculture goods as well
as all products the UK would apply the
u.s. customs code in Northern Ireland
it would allow Northern Irish businesses
to bring goods in the cigar market
without without restrictions which is
essential to avoid red border the text
of the protocol also makes clear that
the Northern Irish economy retains
unfettered market access to the rest of
UK the UK's request Northern Ireland
will apply all the rules of the single
market for electricity the digital
German this is in this interest of the
economy of Northern Ireland and iron
this single EU UK customs territory
would mean that UK Goods get tariffs and
quota free access to the eu27 market for
competition to be open and fair in such
a single customs territory we had agreed
provisions and stated competition
taxation social and environmental
standards this will this will guarantee
that both EU and UK manufacturing will
compete on a level playing field an
essential condition for the single
customs territory to cover fisheries and
aquaculture products will be to agree
between the Union and UK and access to
waters and fishing opportunities over
all these backstops shows that we have
been able to find common ground and meet
our common objectives number one to
protect a Good Friday Agreement in all
its dimensions north-south cooperation
and all Island economy number two to
preserve the integrity of the EU single
bucket and Ireland's place in it three
to respect the UK's territorial
integrity and constitutional father for
to protect the common travel area
between Ireland and the UK finally let
me repeat that this backstop is not
meant to be used our objective remains
to reach the new agreement between the
US and the UK
before the end of the position he places
Imam is able to move and and this leads
me to my final point which relates to
the framework for the future
relationship which is part of this sort
of an annotated outline in which we're
publishing at the same same time we're
preparing and we will be ready to start
that negotiation the very day after the
United Kingdom withdraws from the
European Union on the 30th of March 2019
now what we have today is an outline of
a political statement and we're drawing
the the basis for an ambitious
partnership which we want which is a
free trade area based on regulatory and
customs cooperation in depth and with a
level playing field our objective is to
abolish customs duties and quotas for
all goods based on what we're proposing
in the withdrawal agreement at single
customs territory of course as the
European Council gave me a mandate there
that will be the condition the condition
of a new agreement on fisheries will
apply then there will be sectoral
agreements which are needed and expected
in transport and energy said cooperation
on internal security police and judicial
cooperation and of course and this is an
important point for the whole of Europe
in foreign policy and external security
and defence of course at this stage as I
said it's a annotated outline the basis
of a plan we're going to start working
with the 27 member states and I will
start tomorrow with the European
Parliament on this draft political
declaration the objective of course
being with the United Kingdom to
finalize the deck
raishin in order to be able to present
it to the european council ladies and
gentlemen we as you know we've reached a
crucial stage an important moment in
this extraordinary negotiation which we
entered into at the request of the
United Kingdom there is still a lot of
work I know that the path is still long
that may well be difficult to guarantee
an orderly withdrawal and beyond the
orderly withdrawal beyond the orderly
separation to build something to build
an ambitious and sustainable partnership
with the United Kingdom there is still
work to be done here in this house under
the authority of the President
jean-claude Juncker with the College of
Commissioners and with all the
Commission's departments which I want to
thank most personally for their work and
then over the road with the President
Donald Tusk and his teams the the
Austrian presidency and all the
different presidencies which have in the
past and in the future and the 27
governments who have always shown me
their trust and of course not least mr.
tarney in the European Parliament mr.
Furr have stat and all the members of
the brexit steering group who have
always shown their trust in me and their
vigilance I must say I have worked with
my team and in the name of the European
institutions and I shall continue to
work in precisely the same way
methodically and in the same respect the
same very great respect that I have for
the United Kingdom this negotiation has
never been in my mind and never will be
one against the other
never I have always said that we're
negotiating with the United Kingdom not
against the United
kingdom and in the respect of their
sovereign choice the choice they made to
leave the European Union and tonight as
I said it's it's a crucial step towards
this orderly withdrawal that that step
is a condition the very basis for the
trust which we need in negotiating a new
partnership the United Kingdom will
remain our friend partner and Ally
Teresa may this evening stated that we
taken a decisive step a decisive step
and tonight within my own
responsibilities as the negotiator for
the European Union I believe that we
have made decisive progress possibility
as the you negotiator I consider that we
have achieved decisive progress should
oversee Tatas let's see we can now
switch to your questions I will start
with you a grievance if I may I'd like
to ask about the negotiation on the
iteration ship two questions you sent
just now that you will continue to work
do you mean that you yourself are going
to negotiate this future relationship
which isn't that withdrawal agreement
anymore but it's the next step I infer
that you will continue to lead this
negotiations and have a more specific
question about these negotiations and
the objective the time is less than two
years up to the end of the transition
period
you haven't said unless I'm mistaken how
long the transition period could last
for in addition so
are you hopeful that the agreement can
be glued soon enough or do you think
that this withdrawal greement and the
outline we have today is sufficient
basis for us to feel that that agreement
can be donated much more quickly than
other trade agreements in the past your
last sentence provides part of the
answer in fact I said that these were
exceptional extraordinary negotiations
with a country to which very close this
is after all an ecosystem the single
market which we've built up within our
kingdom of last 41 years so we haven't a
very distant starting point agreements
will constitute the future partnership
with the United Kingdom I don't think
that these agreements will need as much
time as we needed for other trade
agreements with countries which were
much further way in regulatory terms in
terms of standards and sometimes also
geographically secondly your right to
recall the following point the
withdrawal agreement is perhaps a basis
as regards the backstop but there is the
political declarations will be short but
very precise as the European leaders as
the European Parliament want you have
the outline of that declaration in this
annotated plan it's a document which is
by no means artificial it's the result
of precise benchmarking we've carried
out for months now so I have my mandate
which flows from the March guidelines of
the European Council this is ambitious
and there's also the white paper
resulting from the checkers meeting a
useful document on the base of these two
documents we've carried out this
benchmarking and we have found errors of
conversions which I outlined in telegram
style earlier though and negotiating
directors will be drawn up I imagine
that all the relevant Commission DG's
will be involved there be various groups
they'll be coordination that's why I
think that it is feasible to construct
the essentials of this future
partnership within this short
transition period because we've got the
basis and my final reply is this there's
only one point which isn't fleshed out
in my document here that is the time
which it may take for the transition
period to be extended by a common
agreement so this is an option there
could be an extended transition period
if that is agreed but we haven't fleshed
it out it will be the next few weeks
here's the mic please thank you very
much mr. Bernier um could you tell us
please what contingency planning or
plans you might have up your sleeve if
the UK Parliament does not approve this
deal so you have a draft deal now
between the negotiators and the two
sides but what happens if the UK
Parliament votes it down and if I may
also it says in the EU UK joint reports
that future UK EU relationship will be
built on the single customs territory
provided for in the withdrawal agreement
does this mean that the UK will stay
inside some kind of customs union with
the EU in the future thank you so you to
clear what is written in this draft
comment declaration this annotated plan
is the subject of an agreement you've
often heard me say here that I do of
course along with my team follow the
political discussions in the Russia
Kingdom my door has always been open to
politicians who wish to express their
views who was wish to listen to our
views so I think that that is only what
is to be expected
the British discussion is very
stimulating but I won't make any
comments Mrs May said this is the best
possible agreement in the current
circumstances along with the United
Kingdom
oh we've worked on the backstop scenario
which we need in order to avoid there
ever being a hard border on the island
of Ireland
so there no tariffs there be no tariffs
no quotas on Goods and indeed it is
legitimate for that a proposal to be
flanked by a level playing field that's
a voluntary deliberate agreement between
two partners who respect each other this
Agreement offers a basis for future
negotiations and that is in our common
interest okay let's move on wait until
the mic comes thank you
what's your body if I could ask you as
politely as possible could you respond
to this point in English so that it's
completely understood back in the UK is
this now a take-it-or-leave-it deal for
the UK Parliament is there any
possibility of coming back for further
negotiation if it's rejected the the to
negotiate of the two negotiating team
have taken their responsibility the
British government has taken today this
evening its responsibility and now
everybody on both sides have to take
terrorists possibility
[Music]
missiny television system ameliorating
swiss salvation so there'll be the court
of justice involved etc we're talking
about sir customs arrangements would it
be a third country would it be a third
country from the 29th of March onwards
of men in the transition period the
United Kingdom voted democratically in a
sovereign fashion and decided to leave
the European Union that proves that it's
possible and that will be the case the
answers yes on the 29th of March well it
depends whether we use summertime or
British time anyway on the 29th of March
the UK will become a third country and
if you read this carefully if you read
this document carefully you will see the
conditions set out the conditions under
which we're organizing the orderly
withdrawal of the United Kingdom from
the European Union and at the same time
there are many third countries with
which we and they wish to have closer
relations are not going to come back to
our when then staircase but there are
third countries in the European Economic
Area which are members full members of
the single market and there are
governance relations and the Court of
Justice is not excluded from these
governance relations these countries
have with us
so yes the UK will be third country our
firm and this is a deep conviction of
mine because I have immense respect 32
Kingdom that's final that we shall
remain neighbours friends allies and
partners
so the whole point of this declaration
which I've outlined is this the Hazzard
governed ministers and ambassadors and
they within Parliament in the UK have
well worked on this this sets out the
ways and means of establishing this
future partnership which is in our
mutual interest as Paul says point
because we've neglected the French press
so I'll take a French question now see
thank you to two brief questions first
the 27 have been amazingly United
considering all the divisions in the
European Union in other areas why have
they been so United what is the reason
and what is your personal feeling pride
satisfaction tightness you will you
would have observed this unity
I am at the heart of these negotiations
the unity is genuine it is robust and by
no means artificial and it hasn't come
down from heaven now I've had all sorts
of contacts with their state and
government with European Parliament and
many other players and throughout these
contacts in 2016 and 2017 I felt that
people took what was happening very
seriously the the brexit vote was a
thunderclap and there was a new attitude
on the other side of the Atlantic the
American administration's relationship
with the EU are changed and just think
also of stability or instability there's
a long list of terrorist attacks which
hit so many European cities in
particular and there's instability all
around the Mediterranean in the Middle
East as well now I could add the
exacerbation of natural disasters which
aren't all natural there's all sorts of
consequences of climate change this is
what we've observed recently and so
people take ministration very seriously
and they are willing to shoulder their
responsibilities and this is what I've
observed among European politicians and
that is the spirit in which they took
note of brexit in June 2016
in a few days few days later in their
first guidelines they expressed a
composition I wasn't there yet I wasn't
there yet at the time I came here to
nurture this unity
first of all with sport of present
Jonker I proposed an unconventional
method that of total transparency so
immediate communication of the
negotiation documents being available to
talk to you and European politicians and
as a result my team goes to Kurata to
the ambassador's to the ministers the
European Council mr. tose invites me so
in real time my team and I almost
everyday report on the state
negotiations and that produces trust and
it enhances unity the words there's more
more collective ownership and we wanted
people to take account of everything is
a stake there's so much at stake and the
same transparency applies to the
European Parliament the breasted
steering group and that's the
president's conference in in in
Strasbourg as well so III meet ministers
the national parliaments - the trade
unions the employers in each country
there won't be any national ratification
of the stage but ladies and gentlemen
many elements of future relationship
whether the legal nature of the
agreements so we need or other aspects
will beaten mixed agreements they will
require national ratification unanimous
ratification by 27 national parliaments
and perhaps certain regional burns - so
we can to abide by that method because
it's the key to
trust and unity and personally I hope
that this unity which we've constructed
in these negative negotiations can be
used as a basis so as to a work on a
positive agenda the positive gender
which the opinion needs so how do feel
today
but not self-satisfaction
I don't feel smug therefore for reasons
which have to do with my regret about
brexit there's no value-added there but
we've done lot of work we've worked well
that's why I wish to thank the great
team which I've led and and other teams
too I feel that this is a very important
step it's fundamental it's a kind of
prerequisite a prerequisite to have an
agreement on an orderly withdrawal
because what to me is much more
important is the future relationship
with the UK over and above that this
separation over and above that decision
taken by the UK we want to negotiate
with this great country of course we're
tired I hope that I'm disguising it well
but we still have the energy and the
determination which this unity and Trust
lend us Thank You Shannon Slade you have
to file your stories Jim here on the
right from the Financial Times so in the
in the draft withdrawal agreement
there's now this rendezvous for July
2020 to take what what are actually some
very crucial decisions on on Ireland and
how to prevent a hard border in Ireland
are you not worried that by setting this
kind of rendezvous date in mid 2020
you're not in fact but what you're what
you are in fact doing is postponing some
of the hard choices that need to be made
spawning some of the difficult
negotiations that might need to be had
rather than solving these issues now
thank you Jim
Jim now and for a while
if this draft international agreement
this draft treaty is finalized and
ratified then we'll also do our
responsibilities all the different
players will play their role the the the
Parliament the the UK Parliament and and
on our side there'll be a transition
period now during that period the the
current situation stays its preserved
and in particular in Ireland which gives
us time that's the point it's short time
as someone said but there's time to work
on the future relationship and our
interest is not to remain in a
transition period our interest our
common interest is as soon as possible
to have a real sustainable partnership
on all those subjects I mentioned
earlier on that's the point we're not
pushing anything back we're not
deferring anything we're taking things
in order in the right order an orderly
withdrawal and we're practically there I
would say and then you outline the
framework of a future relationship
that's the right order in which to do
things no one's pushing things back
things that should have been dealt with
straight away we're simply doing things
in the right order and if there were to
be difficulties agreeing on this future
relationship then there are two
possibilities limited extension in time
to give ourselves more time the
transition and then and then this new
operational backstop which takes account
of our common requirements that the Good
Friday Agreement our requirement on the
integrity of the single market and the
requirements that the UK have which we
respect to preserve their territorial
integrity so I do really think that
we've taken our responsibilities we've
dealt with now what had to be dealt with
now in a very specific and precise where
you may be rather surprised about how
precise and dense this Texas because
it's an international agreement which
has to provide legal certainty to
everyone and then very quickly we engage
and seek solutions for the future
partnership tomorrow as I said there's
going to be a technical briefing my team
Sabine Stephanie will be here and other
members of the team so you'll have time
to sleep on this read it in the detail
and you'll have all the right questions
tomorrow morning thank you very much see
you tomorrow at 11 o'clock for the
technical briefing
[Music]